[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 les titres de ce
mercredi 4 octobre projet tornado non ce
n'est pas le nom d'un film mais d'une
expérimentation lancée par la communauté
d'agglomération rambouillet territoire à
l'occasion du rendez vous de la mobilité
pendant trois ans des véhicules
électriques autonomes sont testés sur le
territoire explications en début
d'édition 378 communes franciliennes en
sont déjà équipés linky doit remplacer
d'ici 2021 les anciens compteurs
électriques conçus par inédit ce pour
mieux gérer notre consommation et
faciliter la transition énergétique
pourtant associations élus s'inquiètent
de l'installation de ce côté compteur
connectés notamment dans le sud des
yvelines recevons et david jutier
conseiller municipal écologiste à
rambouillet enfin c'est un rendez vous
annuel à plaisir la 24e fête du miel se
tient à le week-end prochain temps fort
pour l'apiculture avec invité d'honneur
et animations au programme
on en parle dans ce journal avec jacky
boisseau apiculteurs et organisateurs de
cette fête du miel 12000 on ouvre ce
journal par le chiffre du jour environ
12 mille familles franciliennes sont
logés actuellement à l'hôtel dans le
cadre de l'hébergement d'urgence
dispositif financé par l'état
c'est un dernier recours quand il n'y a
plus de places en centre d'hébergement
al'approche de l'hiver le samu social de
paris alerte sur le sujet et les nuitées
hôtelières disponibles viennent à
manquer et début septembre par exemple
en une journée le samu social n'a pas pu
trouver de solution pour 314 famille
dont plus de 500 enfants un bus ce sans
conducteur une navette dirigé par à un
ordinateur le futur se développe à
rambouillet territoire la communauté
d'agglomération a organisé le week-end
dernier son rendez-vous de la mobilité
avec en toile de fond une problématique
principale comment se déplacer demain
éléments de réponse avec david
charpentier et nicolas kirillovitch une
navette rouge qui se déplacent sans
bruit mais surtout sans chauffeur voilà
peut-être à quoi ressemblera le véhicule
que nous emprunterons dans quelques
années pour faire nos courses ou aller
au travail
la communauté d'agglomération de rambo
et présenter son projet tourne à dos au
public ce week end
un projet qui vise à développer les
technologies des véhicules autonomes et
portées par le constructeur automobile
renault
l'occasion aussi de se projeter dans
quelques années et d'imaginer des
navettes et voiture ou le chauffeur est
remplacé par des capteurs gps et caméras
en premier on a besoin d'eux des bois
est ce qu'il ya en face donc il ya les
caméras
des vidéos de ces caméras des vidéos il
faut qu'il dise à l'ordinateur
qu'est ce qu'il ya c'est un piéton c'est
un véhicule gnv l'a donc fait il fait la
classification non mais aussi il faut
qu'ils sa caméra décès ces capteurs ils
me disent à quelle distance et 1b un
autre véhicule par rapport à mon
véhicule dont il mesure la distance les
véhicules autonomes sont désormais
tester pour 3 ans sur le territoire de
rambouillet et en plus de l'intérêt
technologique évident d'un tel projet
l'utilité est aussi vitale pour les
zones rurales et cette mobilité fait
partie j'allais dire des deux enjeux de
ce territoire qui émane de la demande à
la fois des citoyens des élus sert la
mobilité en ce sens je vais d'un point à
un autre et un autre sujet qui n'est
effectivement ne concerne pas
aujourd'hui qui est aussi la fibre
puisque ces territoires ont besoin
d'être connecté et la problématique
aujourd'hui c'est qu'ils sont très peu
donc la mobilité est un point important
les premiers véhicules sans chauffeur
devrait rouler dans des conditions
réelles en 2020 dans le sud yvelines
une fois les technologies au point et le
risque d'accident presque nul
un accueil sur ce plateau david jutier
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes élus europe
ecologie les verts au conseil municipal
de rambouillet vous siéger dans
l'opposition
et vous c'est également au conseil
communautaire de rambouillet à
territoire avant de parler des compteurs
linky vous êtes venus pour ça sur ce
plateau je voulais vous faire élire ce
réagir sur ce sujet le projet tornado
qui vous conseillent également qu'est ce
que vous en pensez de ce projet mais moi
je pense que on avait d'autres priorités
en matière de mobilité transports dans
le sud yvelines que de se lancer dans ce
qui est quand même principalement du
gadget et en plus ça moyen à moyen terme
plus de plus de 3 ans ce dont on a
besoin dans le sud yvelines s'est
immédiatement du transport à la demande
des des transports en commun améliorer
les circulations douces qui sont
complètement délaissé moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est la mobilité pour tout
le monde tout de suite et pas des
gadgets du futur qui font plaisir à
certains parce que ça permet de se
mettre en avant de faire de beaux
événements comme on a vu ce week-end
mais qui résolvent en rien les problèmes
de quotidiens de mobilité de transport
des suds illinois vous l'avez sans doute
déjà dans votre
et vous l'aurez bien tôt line qui
poursuit son déploiement se compteurs
intelligents et connectés à internet et
communique automatiquement aînés disent
vos données de consommation en
électricité en région parisienne il doit
remplacer six millions d'anciens
compteurs d'ici 2021 378 communes
franciliennes en sont déjà équipés et
certaines ne le voit pas d'un bon oeil
david juillet vous avez vous organisé
dimanche une réunion publique à charge
contre linky pour vous ce déploiement
est une opération dangereuse pourquoi
alors la réunion qu'on a organisées
n'était pas spécialement à charge elle
était avant tout une première réunion
d'information puisque il y a dans ce
déploiement massif de 35 millions de
nouveaux compteurs et moi je préfère les
appeler des capteurs est d'ailleurs le
terme il n'est pas noir il est avant
tout du président d'aînés dit ce sont
des capteurs à donner et non pas
vraiment maintenant des compteurs
électriques cette réunion a été là pour
informer les utilisateurs et les
utilisatrices puisque ce déploiement
il se fait sans aucune concertation sans
aucune information et à marche forcée il
faut bien le dire
alors pourquoi est-ce que c'est
dangereux pourquoi est ce que nous on se
bat contre lyn titre on se bat pas
contre un compteur électrique c'est pas
ça le problème
on se bat contre lyn qui est son monde
c'est à dire la vision globale dans
laquelle le linky est déployée d'abord
je les dis elle est déployée sans aucune
concertation
premièrement lors de l'essai lors il
fallait que je dédie ce livre est le
minimum quand on installe quelque chose
chez les gens d'aussi important qu'un
capteur qui va récupérer toutes vos que
données de consommation qui va les
envoyer à un opérateur sans aucune
transparence
le minimum c'est quand même de demander
leur avis aux gens et de les informer
d'autant que ce capteur linky il envoie
du courant à l'intérieur du réseau
domestique
il émet des ondes électromagnétiques
dont on ne sait pas exactement quel
effet elles peuvent avoir elles viennent
en tout cas augmenter le niveau de
pollution électromagnétique des foyers
ça c'est certain
un étang risque enfin mettez en avant un
risque pour la santé aussi c'est ça ou y
avoir un risque pour la santé nous ce
qu'on demande c'est que le principe de
précaution soit appliqué et que celles
et ceux qui ne souhaitent pas rajouter
un appareil producteur d' onde
électromagnétique chez eux le puisse
tout simplement alors qu'aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas le cas on le leur impose donc
le premier problème il est là on impose
à
monde et souvent par la force et sans
rien demander un capteur qui va
collecter des données qui va les envoyer
à un opérateur inédit ce qui depuis est
à se déclarer comme opérateur big data
c'est à dire capable de gérer des
données de masse mais l'idée avancée
avant tout c'est de mieux gérer sa
consommation peut être aussi faciliter
la la transition énergétique
ça c'est qu'on aime parce que aussi cet
argument là évidemment qu'on devrait y
être sensible s'il était vrai mais ce
n'est pas vrai c'est pas parce que vous
installez un nouveau compteur chez un
particulier ou une entreprise ou
n'importe quel autre entité et que vous
donnez au foyer la possibilité par une
interface web parce que c'est ça en fait
à faire il est connecté à internet link
y voilà vous avez un accès à un portail
qui vous donne de votre votre
consommation à l'historique de votre
consommation donc les économies
d'énergie qu'on nous promet avec linky
elles viennent pas du tout de
l'opérateur lui-même elles viennent pas
d'une meilleure régulation globalement
du réseau elles viennent des éco gestes
que pourraient faire les utilisateurs et
les utilisatrices en ayant une meilleure
connaissance de leur consommation
et ça on a montré absolument partout il
ya des groupes d'étude de forme et il ya
eu des tests de faire un peu partout en
europe que ça marche les premières
semaines parce que la pose du compteur
et est accompagné d'une sensibilisation
et de l'information et à ce moment là
les risques réglant le cas en plus mais
très rapidement les habitudes revient
dès de toute façon si on doit faire
tourner une machine si on doit
réfrigérée ces aliments on le fait qu'on
sache ne pas que ça consomme donc les
économies d'énergie elles ne viennent
pas majoritairement du conteur ou du
capteur mais concrètement quels sont
aujourd'hui les moyens d'action on voit
qu'il ya des communes qui ont pu
s'opposer à ce compteur je pense à la
commune de bondy qui a qui avait pris un
arrêté anti link hic le maire s'est
retrouvé devant le tribunal
administratif qui lui a donné tort
aujourd'hui quels sont les moyens
d'action pour produire aujourd'hui en
france plus de 400 communes qui ont
délibéré pour s'opposer au déploiement
de ces
de ces capteurs communicants linky ça
veut dire que l'inquiétude elle est
forte aujourd'hui jusqu'à présent est né
dix passer en force c'est à dire qu'il
en voyait même pas ses propres troupes
sur le terrain mais il fait appel à des
sous traitants et on y reviendra si vous
voulez mais il ya quelque chose de tout
à fait signe à déjà arrivé à la fin de
cet accord est de conclure très
rapidement
effectivement aujourd'hui est né dix
passe outre et passe en force donc c'est
à chacun et à chacune de se saisir des
documents les lettres types pour envoyer
à inédit se trouve sur sur internet très
très simplement pour refuser la pose du
compteur et s'en protéger et et puis
agir individuellement
juste un mot quand même sur sur l'impact
sur l'emploi parce que c'est quelque
chose aussi qui est mis en avant et né
dix nous dit qu'en déployant linky il
créé dix mille emplois
et ça aussi c'est un mensonge aussi
aussi faux que le fait qu'on va faire
des économies d'énergie avec avec
l'hymne qui se seront dix mille emplois
supprimés chez les sous-traitants qui
aujourd'hui pose le linky qui ensuite
une fois cette mission terminée verront
leur emploi disparaître parce que les
relève à pied et toutes les opérations
de maintenance qui sont faites je
manuellement s'il vous plaît ne seront
plus effectuées sur le terrain donc le
seul avantage du leem qui il va
directement à aînés 10 sans qu'il y ait
aucune transparence aucune concertation
et bien entendu aucun bénéfice sur la
consommation et sur la transition
énergétique
merci david jutier pour ses réponses
rappel vous êtes conseiller municipal
d'opposition à rambouillet sous
l'étiquette europe écologie les verts
merci se sentait à présent l'association
france alzheimer yvelines orgue in a
organisé une distribution la semaine
dernière quelques jours après la journée
mondiale consacrée à la maladie et des
manchons sensorielle ont été remis aux
patients de l'hôpital gérontologique de
chevreuse
ce sont là des gants spécifique objectif
d'étendre les personnes atteintes par la
pathologie
reportage de michael et demi d'euros
c'est une première dans les yvelines les
patients atteints de la maladie
d'alzheimer de l' hôpital gérontologique
de chevreuse se sont vus offrir des
manchons ou plutôt des gants de
stimulation sensorielle une technique
importée de grande bretagne par une
écossaise kara garcia qui habite
aujourd'hui orgeval
j'aime bien tricoté et j'ai vu que ça se
faisait en grande bretagne ces manchons
et lors de vacances au mois de février
18 ans avec ma mère qui était content
aussi je me suis dit tiens je vais voir
en france en recentrant si ça se fait et
sur internet veut rien vu puis j'ai
contacté monsieur fourni de
l'association france alzheimer yvelines
qui m'a dit qu'effectivement et ne
connaissez pas mais qui serait très
intéressé pour développer l'idée les
mouflons distribuer ce vendredi 29
septembre ont tous été confectionnés à
la main bénévolement par des couturières
amateurs tout a été pensé pour relaxer
les patients dont près de nous avons des
textures de l'aisne qui sont
en sont différentes et des objets a
touché à manipuler un petit cordon et
puis à l'intérieur donc il ya aussi une
poche qui peut servir comme une petite
cachette en fait pour mettre une photo
vos choix et seydou et ben les mains
sont donc au chaud à l'intérieur et puis
on peut toucher l'extérieur après une
première prise en main verdict c'est
bonaventure pour l'hiver c'est pour lui
oui ça me plaît il s'appelait là tout le
monde
de nouvelles distributions gratuites
sont prévues dans les maisons de
retraite et les hôpitaux yvelinois dans
les prochains mois la maladie
d'alzheimer touche entre 15000 et dix
neuf mille personnes dans le département
il a été le premier ensemble de bureaux
construits à saint quentin en yvelines
en 1976 l'immeuble international a
entamé son lifting le caresser son
nouveau nom va accueillir plus de vingt
mille mètres carrés de bureaux et 131
logements à montigny le bretonneux
livraison prévue fin 2010 9 travaux de
démolition et de désamiantage sont en
cours le site vise une quadruple
certification environnementale
ce serait une première en france
toujours à saint quentin en yvelines
mais quelques kilomètres plus loin
depuis la rentrée le centre le centre
équestre de l'île de loisirs a changé de
nom et de gestionnaire il est devenu le
sky équitation possibilité désormais de
réserver ses cours sur internet et de
payer en ligne des démarches simplifiées
mais l'offre reste la même camille
lambert
un peu farceur les nouveaux venus du
centre équestre de l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines
julie est monitrice d'équitation depuis
deux ans son rôle former les jeunes
cavaliers pour la compétition et surtout
développer la relation avec la nature
c'est un court avec beaucoup de nouveaux
projets dont des bébés et des tout
jeunes lever tout juste des bourines
c'est pour ça que c'est un petit peu
branlant au départ mais faut les former
ses cavaliers là qui déforme du trou sur
les coins et à des complicités qui se
crée il ya des affinités qui se créent
et on essaie depuis pdg ses affinités là
parce que surtout sur du dressage de
jeunes chevaux
c'est le plus important fait là vraiment
vraiment besoin comme julie six autres
moniteurs et soigneurs travaille ici
depuis le 28 août la structure est
devenue ski équitation et à changer de
gestionnaire la région ile-de-france
reste propriétaire mais c'est la société
privée dahlia qui a repris les rênes
si l'offre du centre reste la même les
modalités elles ont évolué un nouveau
site internet une nouvelle page facebook
et les adhérents ou mêmes extérieur on
possibilité maintenant de pouvoir
s'inscrire en ligne d'effectuer des
règlements en ligne de pouvoir régler
aussi en plusieurs fois
ce qui était quelque chose de beaucoup
plus complexe quand on est géré par par
l'état après 20 ans d'existence le
centre équestre compte aujourd'hui 250
adhérents débutants ou confirmés
cette nouvelle gestion devrait lui
apporter un coup de jeune avec quelques
investissements
une nouvelle carrière et une dizaine de
boxe sont prévues chaque année la 24e
fête du miel se déroule ce week end au
château de plaisir deux jours
d'animations dédiées à l'apiculture
francilienne au nectar de fleurs et à
ses produits dérivés bonsoir jacky
boisseau donc soit vous êtes le
président de l'association plaisir
village animation qui organise cet
événement vous êtes également apiculteur
depuis une trentaine d'années quel
intérêt justement de consacrer un week
end au miel de faire découvrir
re découvrir ce produit est bien chaque
année on refait découvrir donc toutes
les valeurs donc du miel qui sont
produits sur l'île de france est
uniquement sur l'île de france c'est une
spécificité dire qu'on ne souhaite pas
avoir de revendeurs et donc à voir donc
des miels typique de noël de nos régions
de des hauts plateaux d'île de france si
je peux me permettre reste important de
valoriser ce ce projet francilien
bien sûr parce qu'il y à des produits
qui sont on a une nature riche en région
parisienne et notamment sur la région de
plaisir où on a donc des gains de tintry
grandes forêts qui sont à proximité et
dont les abeilles se gargarise
rencontrons pas renié l'on pense bien
sûr aux côtés du statique tout de suite
mais gustatif mais c'est aussi un
produit avec de nombreux bienfaits
génial oui on l'utilisent depuis la nuit
des temps un c'est un produit magique
qui est utilisée aussi bien pour la
médecine que pour les bienfaits de la
gastronomie y avait l'air beaucoup de
boissons dans l'antiquité au moyen âge
qui est à base de miel ou les vins
l'hydromel aux hydromel donc c'est quoi
une boisson certainement plus ancien que
le que les uns existe et donc c est un
produit que nous propose aussi à
découvrir
alors justement vous êtes apiculteurs du
depuis une trentaine d'années alors
c'est une passion fait une passion une
passion ça n'était pas ma profession
d'accord j'étais donc collaborateurs
renouer donc pour me déstresser donc de
mes activités puisque j'étais acheteur
chez renault j'ai trouvé cette ce moyen
donc de me ressourcer et si on revient à
cette fête du miel l'idée aussi avant
tout il ya une vocation pédagogique
c'est oui d'informer sur les premières
produits clés première productrice de
mails du miel qui sont qui sont les
abeilles alors sur ces deux jours donc
il y aura effectivement des ateliers
pédagogiques puisque c'est notre
vocation premier on n'est pas là pour
faire un business ci est essentiellement
pour faire de la pédagogie il ira donc
deux extraction qui seront faites une le
samedi après-midi vers 15h30 ça se fait
sous forme d'ateliers si c'est un
atelier d'extraction
le public peut venir participer et
visualiser en live donc la récolte du
miel et puis une extraction qui se fait
qui sera fait aussi le dimanche
après-midi dans le même état d'esprit
avec de nombreux ateliers pour les
enfants parce qu'on ne s'adresse
essentiellement aux enfants qui sont
donc porteurs de messages certainement
beaucoup plus que les adultes
comment rassure justement les enfants on
peut avoir peur des abeilles avoir peur
de la piqûre d'abeille et bien c'est une
c'est une image forte que les parents
transmettent parce qu'en fin de compte
sur cette lettre at war aussi à tort et
en général ce que je propose - c'est
selon les selon météo et selon les
conditions mais on met une petite goutte
de miel sur le droit et les abeilles
viennent se poser sur deux doigts et
c'est quelque chose de magique pour les
enfants
côté sensibilisation aussi il ya
peut-être l'idée de parler je sais pas
de l'espèce des abeilles peut-être
qu'ils ont au danger par l'oci ont
l'idée lure donc de nos espèces
endémiques qui sont l'abeille noire qui
est qui existe depuis à peu près quinze
ou vingt mille ans depuis la dernière
glaciation et on essaye donc de
travailler et de sensibiliser les
apiculteurs et la population à ce risque
majeur qui est la disparition de notre
abeilles donc locale
alors pour cette fête du miel chaque
année il ya des invités d'honneur qui
sont ils s'étaient alors cette année
nous avons invité l'ambassadeur du
cameroun à paris puisque nous avons
réalisé au mois d'avril une mission au
cameroun pour faire un audit et une
formation sur la filière agricole au
cameroun
et donc on a fait un retour donc vers
l'ambassadeur du cameroun qui je
l'espère sera présent les dégustations
aussi au programme
je vais dire grâce à ces essentiels
c'est l'après el al et dégustation ce
sont des choses essentielles pour pour
faire vivre cette fête du miel on a donc
aussi bien les dégustations donc de miel
venir
pour lui les rives et les produits
dérivés des boissons médiévales tout ce
qui peut graviter autour de retour du
miel là qu'on pourra goûter aussi les
boissons qui se faisait autrefois on
peut goûter aussi les boissons notamment
liederman un dernier mot peut-être sur
la fête il ya une exposition aussi qui
est programmé pour cette fête du miel
alors les expositions sont des
expositions pédagogiques sont
essentiellement les découvertes donc de
nos prédateurs aussi ce sont les frelons
asiatiques qui sont des prédateurs
redoutables qui sont arrivés en france
et on essaie de sensibiliser le public à
la reconnaissance donc des ce2 c'est de
cet insecte qui est en train de faire de
très gros ravages en région parisienne
enfin pas forcément qu'en région
parisienne d'ailleurs surtout sur
l'ensemble de la france
merci jacques boisseaux d'avoir été avec
nous je le rappelle vous êtes
apiculteurs organisateurs aussi de cette
fête du miel la 24e édition à se tient
ce week-end dans les communs du château
de plaisir rendez vous de 10 heures à 18
heures l'entrée est libre et pour plus
d'informations vous pouvez vous rendre
sur le site internet qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran a dit le pr l'église
saint-vincent-de-paul fête ses 50 ans
toute cette semaine une série
d'événements expositions conférences
concerts et même une messe anniversaire
dimanche à 10h30
écoutez le curé de la paroisse au micro
de nicolas kirillovitch qui nous
explique l'importance de cet événement
d'abord parce que je crois qu'il ya un
pas de d'avenir s'en passer et qu'il est
donc important de se tourner vers notre
passé vers notre histoire notre culture
pour pouvoir envisager sereinement notre
avenir
je crois aussi que c'est très important
de d'honorer les personnes aujourd'hui
encore vivante bien sûr qui ont
participé à la construction de cette
église
et puis toute occasion est bonne pour
faire la fête
il ya beaucoup de d'occasions de pleurer
malheureusement et je crois que bas cela
nous a donné pour qu'on puisse se
réjouir
la danse est particulièrement le break
dance était à l'honneur dimanche dernier
à maurepas près de 150 personnes ont
participé à la qualification pour le
championnat de france de la discipline
une étape du bboy france tour 2010 est
organisée par l'association world step
evans c'était au gymnase de la malle me
donne retour sur l'événement avec
nicolas landry en tournant sur la tête
en équilibre sur les bras ou des tours
de passe-passe la culture hip hop mise à
l'honneur par l'association world step
event de maurepas en co organisant les
qualifications régionales de break dance
pour le championnat de france c'est de
promouvoir le hip hop auprès des jeunes
et auprès de tout public d'ailleurs
puisque le hip hop c'est une culture
c'est une philosophie
et du coup en fait c'est aussi de
pouvoir créer une compétition parce que
effectivement la danse
et culturels mais c'est quand même un
sport plusieurs catégories dans cette
compétition junior girl liboi top rock
écrou chaque breaker à sa préparation sa
technique et son ressenti musicale je
mets chauds je fais quelques mouvements
mais pas trop non plus pourquoi montrer
aux autres que
après une fois qu'on est lancé pour
retour
le but c'est d'être musical tout en
étant technique ça c'est assez difficile
à faire il faut savoir combiner les deux
je joue beaucoup sur l'énergie et
l'agilité et
tout en étant d'être musicale beaucoup
de passe-passe mélangés à des phases
voilà avec des bonds blocage sur la
musique emprise engagé dans la catégorie
bboy cam il s'est arrêté en demi finale
kelis viril lui a remporté le concours
top rock
il est qualifié donc pour les
championnats de france prévus à liévin
le 18 novembre prochain
c'est la journée mondiale des animaux
rendez-vous pour sensibiliser à leur
protection et à la disparition de
certaines espèces et justement avant de
refermer ce journal nous parlons nous
partons sur la trace des animaux
direction le parc animalier de l'espace
rambouillet une plongée en forêt pour
découvrir les habitants de ces bois
c'est avec mathilde et demi depuis une
quarantaine d'années les grands animaux
sauvages de la forêt sont logés dans
l'espace rambouillet qui est devenu un
parc animalier et forestier géré par
l'office national des forêts ici on a
une petite heure effectivement de paris
au coeur de la forêt domaniale de
rambouillet qui fait près de 22 mille
hectares c'est la plus grande forêt à
l'ouest de paris et en particulier à
l'espace rambouillet nous sommes dans un
espace clos de 250 hectares
dans lequel on peut trouver en grande
densité des grands animaux de nos forêts
à savoir des cerfs des chevreuils dédain
et laissant milliers et ce en liberté
aura pas de barrière
il faut passer un peu plus de temps pour
les observer mais il y aura aussi une
dimension différente parce que il ya un
peu de sensationnel
s'éloigner de la ville et du bruit pour
les citoyens urbains en s'immergeant
dans la nature
c'est l'objectif du parc qui développe
de nombreuses activités pour se
rapprocher des animaux proposons des
visites libres donc pour les visiteurs
et puis aussi des visites guidées
accompagné sur cette partie grands
animaux forestier nous avons aussi des
démonstrations de rapaces en vol
trois fois par jour là encore qui sont
en visite libre
et puis d
les prestations des activités un peu à
la carte comme des expériences d'un jour
ça veut dire vivre le métier de
forestier animaliers ou de fauconniers
sur une demi-journée avec des
professionnels de l'office national des
forêts
une expérience naturelle pour les
enfants qui doivent apprendre à
respecter la nature et à trouver des
traces pour pouvoir apercevoir certains
animaux je vais les soli les salles et
les biches moi ça on peut découvrir un
peu les animaux sauvages
enfin plus dans la forêt sauvage
chercher à apprendre à se cacher dans la
forêt pour prêter à demi mot les voir
plein de choses sur les arbres une
balade forestière aux portes de paris
qui peut peut-être nous faire tomber nez
à nez avec quelques mammifères pas lui
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal as
replays est disponible sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
78 excellente soirée à tous
[Musique]